a standoff hostage situation and
shooting all caught on body camera video
by New Mexico police officers
[Music]
pointed at him it started on March 29th
in Albuquerque New Mexico investigators
say a suspect identified as 32 year old
Francisco Macias was high on narcotics
when he assaulted his mother and Aunt
after that he went into the front yard
of his home and fired a gun officials
say there was a brief standoff before
officers arrived
body camera video shows officials
calling for Macias to drop the weapon
when he raised his gun officers opened
fire
[Music]
in all officials fired 36 shots in
macias's Direction he was struck in the
foot
just so you know we've got to cut down
over there
attack loading attack loading check
yourself check yourself you guys good
job stepping over to you guys
body camera video shows officers attempt
to get another view of Macias after he
ran from the scene meanwhile his friend
wrestles The Gun away from him and
throws it over a fence let me step in
front of you
what's up
good morning
drop it let me see your face
officers jump over walls and fences to
close in on Macias
he's over here
they can be heard calling for Macias to
drop the weapon
drop it
[Music]
yeah
let him go
finally officials approach the suspect
who has taken his friend as a hostage
officers fire a less Lethal Weapon in an
effort to get Macias to release the man
when that doesn't work they tase him
Macias was treated for his gunshot wound
he was later charged for false
imprisonment and aggravated assault with
a deadly weapon reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie